if i
win he'll let me go
if you think this has a happy ending you
haven't been paying attention
the rel do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
as you all know hbo's adaptation of
george rr martin's epic fantasy series
was arguably
the most successful television show ever
created
the show has won an incredible amount of
awards
as well as breaking an insane amount of
records
it was estimated that game of thrones
made hbo
billions of dollars just from their
monthly subscriptions alone
game of thrones was on the verge of
becoming the greatest show in television
history
that was until the series ended the way
it did
millions of fans were upset with how
game of thrones ended
ever since the show aired its final
episode i've been wondering
what effect did this have on hbo how
many subscribers did they actually lose
well if this article is accurate we now
have an answer
i want to show you this article i
recently read by cbr
also known as comic book references the
reason why i think this is interesting
because
now we can almost guarantee this will
affect what hbo does with their new
shows in the future
i will explain what i mean by that but
first let me show you what it says in
the article
according to this website hbo lost over
half of its adult viewers after game of
thrones ended
after more than seven years on
television hbo's revolutionary fantasy
series game of thrones
came to an end after eight seasons an
analysis of the last year has revealed
that the show's ending has heavily
impacted hbo's viewership a review of
television networks in 2020
conducted by variety showed that over
the span of the last year
hbo lost 51 percent of its adult
audiences
ages 18 to 49 the significant drop in
audience has been attributed to the
conclusion of game of thrones
which has not yet seen a replacement the
show drew an increasingly large audience
and broke numerous records
resulting in an average of about 12
million viewers by season 8.
now we all know while the series was
generally well received
season 8 became the subject of immense
backlash
with critics and audiences citing
significant departures
from martin's characters as well as a
rush story
i don't think i need to go into all the
reasons fans were upset with the show
now i want to show you what another
source said because i think these
numbers might be a little more accurate
last month the observer reported hbo had
54 million domestic or u.s subscribers
back in 2017.
these numbers included subscribers from
hbo
cinemax and hbo now in recent years
hbo no longer includes cinemax
subscribers into their numbers
in october of 2020 which was only a few
months ago
it was reported hbo had 38 million
u.s subscribers these numbers included
subscribers from hbo
and hbo max only and i think it's safe
to say those numbers would have been
even lower
if hbo didn't just recently release hbo
max
i'm sure they got a nice bump after
releasing the new service
however based on what it says hbo has
lost
roughly 16 million subscribers over the
last three years
now keep in mind these are only the
domestic numbers
this is how many subscribers they lost
in the united states alone
i'm sure they've lost millions of more
subscribers internationally
but i don't see those numbers here now
as bad as that may sound
hbo is still the third largest streaming
service available
behind netflix and hulu their overall
subs are down
after the end of game of thrones but
it's not as catastrophic as some may
have thought
we all knew hbo would lose millions of
subscribers after game of thrones ended
but how many of you thought it would be
this many now it really shouldn't come
as a surprise considering how many of us
signed up for hbo just to be able to see
game of thrones as soon as it aired
even if the show did have an amazing
ending i still think
millions of viewers would have dropped
service as soon as game of thrones ended
now i actually still have hbo as well as
hbo max because i still watch a lot of
their shows and documentaries
let me know if you got rid of hbo as
soon as game of thrones was over
or if you still have it till this day
one of the reasons i am making this
video is because i want to discuss what
effect i think this will have on hbo's
other shows
i know many of you are still worried
about whether or not house of the dragon
will get released
i happen to think it will be a success
even if it's nowhere near as successful
as game of thrones once was
the fact that hbo lost so many
subscribers is one of the reasons i
believe they already gave house of the
dragon a full series order
i think they want to get back as many of
those subscribers as they can
and they need to do it while this story
is still in everyone's mind
hbo better than anyone else knows how
much money they're losing every month
by not having one of these shows on air
that's why they were developing
five different shows at once because all
they really need is for one of them to
work
now they are obviously hoping more than
one of these new shows are successful
but for right now
they just need to get something else out
there while fans are still interested in
george r martin's universe
there is a fine line they will have to
walk because they don't want to rush
anything either
that's one of the reasons millions of
fans saw the game of thrones ending as a
failure
as you all know house of the dragon is
scheduled to release next year
so unless something drastically changes
i fully believe hbo will do everything
they can to make sure they hit their
deadline
i have been a lifelong fan of hbo and
like i was saying before
i not only love their shows but i love
most of their documentaries as well
i like everything from game of thrones
band of brothers
the wire deadwood hard knocks and so
much more
the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
at least when my girls are done with a
man he's still left drawing breath
for the most part
why have you asked me
she believes you'd know
who said that who broke silence
in all your life i had all your love all
your hate all your memory all your pain
it was all the same
thing
oh a long lost leader
somebody must owe him money
as a lifelong fan i really do hope hbo
bounces back with another hit
show now i know some fans don't want
anything to do with another a song of
ice and fire show
because they say they already know how
it ends
that actually doesn't affect me though
the way game of thorns ended wasn't
exactly how george wants his story to
end
i don't look at game of thrones as if it
was written in blood
that was the show's version house of the
dragon however
should have george's ending considering
he has already written how most of those
major events ended hopefully i made
sense there
now at the end of the day house of the
dragon will still be a show version of
the books
but i will stay optimistic for now i do
hope hbo learns from their mistakes
because i want their new series to be a
success i want all of us to be able to
watch another amazing show
like the first four seasons of game of
thrones was are you surprised hbo lost
half of their adult audience or did you
think they would actually lose more
also let me know if you're still a
subscriber of their service
did you keep hbo yourself or did you
drop them as soon as game of thrones
ended
leave me some of your thoughts down
below as always i have to thank everyone
for watching my video
i am grateful for the support that i
still receive i hope everyone has a
great day
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you